quite a while ago we used to do a
recurring segment called
big dick history and it's time to bring
it back out of the vault
yes i forget how we started talking
about this because i am a real history
buff
i love reading about history and then it
somehow got perverted by you freaks
into this segment called big dick
history uh which is something i never
signed on for
but um i am i feel like i've completely
lost control of this podcast
and uh so if the fans wish it
uh i will do as i'm asked okay well it's
gonna come down to this another quiz for
you two
and this is called big dick history the
ideal wang
okay this is just awful i am so excited
this is not the kind of podcast i want
to do it's not the kind of humor i like
to delve into
but uh but uh when captain gourley
is uh is at the helm uh this is what i
must
submit to all right i'm sorry i just i
want to just add i think it's important
to note that i did
win the first one because you cheated on
a question
about a a male porn star so i am the
reigning champion
of the big dick history quizzes i don't
recall
because i care about the world we live
in and real issues
okay in this corner is the champion
sonam of session and in this corner the
contender conan o'brien
all right this is big so this is the
ideal wang
throughout history what i'm gonna do is
name an
era of ancient history and give you
three options into what was the most
popular type of toddler okay this comes
from bustle.com
what toddler is that a real name for uh
sure look i'm running out of synonyms
for
willy okay i caught the old william
carlos williams
okay so what type of william carlos
williams was the most popular
kind of john thomas from that era does
that make sense are we
are we talking like how it's how big it
is
how it angles itself no no just the name
for it no no no sorry it is that it is a
description
it's it will be three different physical
descriptions
and remember because this is an audio
podcast to
answer you have to yell out your name
okay okay you have to remember that
because you never remember that
you just started that's your buzzer okay
all right okay
i i often yell out my own name during
sex
what it's an old dead go ahead good
you're keeping it the narcissist who
yells out his own name during sex
okay come on okay so remember i'm gonna
read three
it you can buzz in with your name at any
time but once you're gonna do that
so you're gonna give us descriptions oh
god it's
like watching paint dry listening to you
excuse me
let me just make sure i understand the
rules you're such a tracy flick right
now just let it go
we have to guess the era no i will tell
you no he'll tell us
what's the best just what's the most uh
positive
description okay yeah it's what people
what was the most
like in vogue type
this is just i mean i love any any game
show where describing how to play it
takes 45 minutes is a failed game show
you know on on wheel of fortune they're
not
pat sajak isn't out there for you know
40 minutes
saying so i'll spin the wheel and when
it ends
on that then that's what you do you see
and then you'll see the letters i have a
question pat
that's my pat sagic impression all right
here we go here we go
ancient egypt and here are the three
types name which one was the most
type of popular penis curvy and girthy
clean and circumcised tall and thin
conan conan
this middle one i'll read them again
curvy and girthy
clean and circumcised tall and thin
conan
yes the first one what the f jesus
christ what
what the curse which one curvy and
girthy kirby and girthy
is incorrect sona you get to have a what
two remaining choices
i'm gonna guess clean and circumcised
because that's correct
that's the one he originally guessed and
to know that i can get the answer right
by guessing what you originally guessed
makes me
feel like i've already won they were
circumcising in ancient egypt they sure
were
yeah what did they what did they use the
tip of a pyramid what did they how do
they do that
they'd have to haul a baby up to the top
of a pyramid
put its uh it's john dewey down there
and then
hit it with a rock this is known from a
surviving
um manuscript called the turin erotic
papyrus
yeah basically more proof that
pornography has always been with us
okay number two ancient greece and rome
and your options are stubby and soft
long and lean or small and uncut
conan conan long and lean
sorry that's incorrect sona um i'm gonna
say stubby just because when i think of
greek men i think of lots of hair so the
first one
what's stubby got to do with hair wait
oh stubby i thought
oh you mean stubbly like they shaved it
like a beer yeah i thought you meant
harry
oh man i'm sorry neither of you are
correct oh no
it's small and uncut if you think of
your great you know grecian art
you see that reflected quite a bit
you think those are small
[Laughter]
i always walk out of museums going jesus
that that baby statue was hung
[Laughter]
that angel was packing serious heat
my wife is always crying to walk out of
the museum
please be quiet okay it is uh one point
sona zero points conan we are on to
number three out of five i'm proud that
i'm listening
yeah yeah no you're not you hate this so
much that you
you hate losing ancient india
my specialty just the tip all are
welcome
and tapered like a wizard's wand sona
yeah tapered like a wizard's wand
i'm sorry that's incorrect conan your
remaining options are just the tip
and all are welcome well i'm gonna go
with
number two all are welcome correct we
are tied up here
on the ideal wayne quiz wow
let me tell you something about this
comes from the kama sutra and that
male sizes of genitals were named for
small medium and large and they were the
hare
the bull and the horse the female
genital sizes were named
deer mare and elephant which is weird
because mare is the medium and male
is the horse that's the large they don't
line up
yeah i just heard our shot at a peabody
disappear
well we're gonna get a peepee body shot
weeks ago talking to
president obama doing my best i've
talked to historians
i've really tried to elevate us and then
you come along
riding your uh
flying wang into the picture and you
you lower the conversational tone so
anyway
i'm happy thank you okay number four
edo period japan number one
huge uncircumcised and veiny number two
delicate dainty and shrouded in silk
or three sharp like a samurai sword
sona i believe the second one the one
shrouded in silk i'm sorry that's
incorrect
conan your options are huge
uncircumcised and veiny or
sharp like a samurai sword it would be
number three sharp like a samurai sword
that is incorrect see that's too obvious
it's huge uncircumcised and veiny
and this is our last question so this is
for all the marbles as it were
all the testicles okay you're just this
is a side of you that's
you shouldn't be proud of this is not oh
i'm not proud
this is just the lowest okay ready
henry viii's england okay
off with its head which means
circumcised prim and proper
or all about the bulge sona
now we both said it at the same time and
you can listen on audio
i am listening on audio you know what
i'll let you have it
that's actually a smart choice yeah
you're doing the monty hall paradox prim
and proper
number two that's incorrect you can take
it
all here yes too wait can you tell me
the other two
off with his head meaning circumcised or
all about the bulge
all about the bulge that's right soda
keeps her championship streak oh my god
nothing makes me happier in life than
beating you at things i can't even tell
you how good this feels
and everything that i've ever done in my
life pales in comparison
to when i beat you at something it just
feels
so fantastic nope you know your way
around a penis
congratulations
congratulations